chile se suma al plan de la tercera
dosis la población de riesgo del país
andino regresó a los centros de
vacunación para obtener una inyección de
refuerzo contra el cob y 19 bueno creo
que me va a ayudar a ver un poco más
[Música]
las autoridades chilenas argumentan la
decisión por la amenaza de las nuevas
variantes como la del está frente a la
que los fármacos administrados ven
reducida ligeramente su eficacia de
todas las vacunas
produce un aumento en los anticuerpos
inicialmente pero pues se produce una
caída sostenida en el tiempo y los
estudios han demostrado que justamente
aproximadamente los 6 meses hay una
disminución así como chile uruguay
israel alemania rusia y francia dieron
luz verde a la llamada dosis de refuerzo
haciendo oídos sordos a los llamados de
la o ms que pide posponer el refuerzo
hasta finales de septiembre para que al
menos el 10% de la población mundial sea
inmunizada
entiendo la preocupación de los
gobiernos para proteger a su población
de la variante delta pero no podemos y
no debemos aceptar que los países que ya
usaron la mayoría de las reservas de
vacunas usen todavía más using even more
of it mientras que en el resto del mundo
las personas más vulnerables continúan
desprotegidas and project ship la
organización mundial de la salud reitera
que el principal foco de aparición de
nuevas variantes son las poblaciones
completamente desprotegidas frente al
virus y que en un mundo globalizado la
salud pública es una cuestión mundial